[Music]
this is the 14th amendment of the
constitution I'm not going to read the
whole thing of it's going to read the
first section all persons born or
naturalized in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof are
citizens of the United States and the
state were in they reside no State shall
make or enforce any law which shall
abridge the privileges or immunities of
citizens of the United States nor shall
any state deprive any person of life
liberty or property without due process
of law in order to deny any person
within its jurisdiction the equal
protection of the laws
any person within its jurisdiction
cannot be denied the equal protection of
its laws to me the Fourteenth Amendment
especially this idea of equal protection
under the law is the whole enchilada for
me first of all when you talk about
protection that implies that there must
be a harm someplace that you're trying
to protect someone from that opens the
door to have a whole discussion about
reality a lot of this stuff floats above
reality it's you know all abstract
principle but to have the equal
protection under the law means that you
you're gonna have some permission for
some activism from the government you're
gonna have some permission to talk about
inequality unequal treatment unfair
treatment for they were they were
causing contemplating african-americans
but they see everybody so I didn't say
you know equal protection under under
the law unless you're a lesbian it's not
what it says it doesn't say equal
protection under the law unless you were
african-american it's not what it says
says if you're in the jurisdiction you
get equal protection under the law
that's radical 10,000 years of human
history that's radical and I think it's
very very important that we
uphold the 14th amendment we talked
about the First Amendment talk about the
Second Amendment you talk about
sometimes the Fifth Amendment but we
don't talk about the 14th amendment
enough equal protection under the law
[Music]